alors que nous adaptions les livres de Veronica et
essayions de comprendre comment utiliser tout le
métier de film pour créer une expérience qui
ressemblait en quelque sorte aux livres, mais sur
grand écran, nous n'avons jamais oublié que Veronica a
vendu 25 millions de livres, je suis toujours très
ouvert d'esprit  changer tant que cela
crée une histoire meilleure et plus forte
Janine prétend que vous êtes tous des
insurgés dangereux si nous devions combiner nos forces
serait imparable ce dont j'ai le plus
peur, c'est lorsque les personnages changent,
il était donc très important pour moi de m'assurer
que  la dynamique entre Tristan pour
rester la même et que vous savez
qu'il ne la dominait pas et puisque cette
histoire de trista était très importante pour
moi qu'elle soit toujours le principal moteur de
l'intrigue que veut-elle avec elle
c'est le sujet parfait le  l'esprit
du livre est le voyage de Chris l'esprit
du livre est une certaine réalité de
la vie émotionnelle